and finally new rule the Fox News
editors who each week highlight one
thing I say about the Democrats that
fits their narrative and then completely
ignores all the [ __ ] I say about
Republicans
might want to go ahead and turn the TV
off right now
because
because we are now only seven months
away from midterm elections that are
poised to make the Republicans much more
powerful so attention must be paid to
where the Republican party is right now
you think with the left going a little
loony over the past few years
Republicans would have seen an opening
to grab the sensible Center
but no
former Republican governor of Ohio and
anti-trumper presidential candidate John
Kasich said of his party in 2019
sometimes you've got to let the fever
break and I think we have a fever and
it's going to break
but it didn't break
and it's not a fever it's more like a
tumor
and tumors don't go away they get worse
normal Republican crazy or you just
shoot guns at things you don't like in
your campaign ads
foreign
[Applause]
even that [ __ ] doesn't even cut it
anymore the new crop are such a bunch of
foaming at the mouth cracking releasers
that Clarence Thomas wants to marry them
[Applause]
I look back at the Republican class of
2010 because that year I remember has
been held up as an example of Republican
kookiness gone wild remember Christine
O'Donnell oh she had been a frequent
guest on my old show a very sweet
sincere jesus-free conservative
ran for the Senate at which time I
played some highlights from her
appearances on Politically Incorrect and
the media seized on Christine's
statement that she had dabbled in
witchcraft as if it was the craziest
thing a republican would ever say
thank you
[Applause]
Congressman Todd Aiken around the same
time caused a media Firestorm when he
said that in cases of legitimate rape
the female body has ways to try to shut
that whole thing down
and Indiana Senate candidate Richard
Murdoch concurred saying even when a
life began in rape it was something God
intended to happen both had to go away
but if a republican Congressman said the
same thing today would they have to I
doubt it since now what they said is
literally the party's active legislative
agenda in multiple States
and I used to think Rex santurnum was
weird for wearing a sweater vest
[Applause]
1009 it was a big deal when Congressman
Joe Wilson yelled out you lie during
Obama's State of the Union Address but
this year Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Lauren bobert repeatedly repeatedly
interrupted Biden at his State of the
Union look at them
excuse me Karen
the president is talking it's not a
black kid you caught trying to use the
pool
no you can't have another skinny
margarita and if you don't sit down this
flight is never getting to Orlando
[Applause]
for all of you who get frustrated
because mansion and Cinema don't vote
like true liberals because they never
were or think Trump is as bad as it's
going to get
remember the first rule of modern
Republican politics they always go lower
because this party has no bottom unless
you count Lindsey Graham
the cookie Republicans of the 2010 era
wouldn't even make the cut today for
extremism and the ones today aren't even
as bad as the ones in the wings where do
you see the incoming group of Facebook
uncles crazy Karen's and some mental
[ __ ] posters coming up
Herschel Walker Senate candidate in
Georgia who freely admits he has a dozen
personalities none of whom you'd want to
sit next to at a wedding
recently came out against evolution
saying science said man came from apes
if that's true why are there still Apes
think about it
[Applause]
you first
and also think about this if Honey Nut
Cheerios came from Cheerios why do we
still have cheerio
think about it
[Applause]
Alaska Senate candidate Kelly chebacca
speaks in tongues otherwise known as
jabbering senselessly
sure take a listen
yeah
pathetic like the people of Alaska would
even vote for some Tim wooded religious
knot
Nevada state treasurer candidate
Michelle Fiore is called lady Trump and
has some interesting policy ideas like
quote arming young hot little girls on
campus so they can kill rapists
maybe they can start a sorority Delta
bus to Kappa
[Applause]
on the topic of Syrian refugees Michelle
fiori said I'm about to fly to Paris and
shoot him in the head myself I'm okay
with putting them down blocking them out
and ending their miserable life
what was Bush's catchphrase
compassionate conservative
former Missouri Republican governor and
now Senate candidate Eric greitens is a
sociopath who's
whose ex-wife says he beat her and the
kids and who resigned the governorship
after being charged with tying up a
woman he was having an affair with in
his basement taking nude pictures of her
and threatening to blackmail her if she
told anyone as Governors do
[Applause]
and look at these two neanderthals
almost coming to blows during a debate
and they're both Republicans
it was so over the top the crowd filed
out in disgust I'm joking of course they
couldn't have eaten it up more if it
were deep fried
[Applause]
and my favorite the Republican running
against AOC in the Bronx is Tina Forte a
self-described viral political
influencer who's happy to sell you a
t-shirt that says I could [ __ ] a better
president
foreign
that is when she's not busy campaigning
underway to the gym
we can do in our [ __ ] pay-per-view
[ __ ] huh how do you like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
[Music]
what are they serving at the Republican
convention these days bath salts
[Applause]
if the GOP still had a platform which
they don't but if they did it would be
[ __ ] you
you think the Republicans of 2010 were
Kooks this crowd looked at those people
like please they've never even
masturbated on a subway